so if joe biden says that we're going to
respond in kind with chemical weaponry
are they going to pause and say well
we don't want to hitch our nation's
wagon to this country america right now
because it's being led by a crazy person
who obviously is mentally incapacitated
to some degree and clearly is not able
to make good decisions or can't even put
out the right words to do so so
there's there's pretty serious national
security ramifications to his mumblings
and and we all see it it's reflected in
the approval numbers but i guarantee you
when capitals around the world right now
they see it too
what do you make of what i would argue
is the
like absolutely extraordinary level of
incompetence of this administration when
it comes to the messaging so for example
when just a couple weeks ago there was
suddenly this rumor that they were going
to use russia was going to use chemical
weapons i did not bother saying a word
about it because it just felt
nonsensical to me because why wouldn't
you in a war of propaganda just be like
yeah the other guy is going to use
chemical weapons that's a pretty good
move
but then
joe biden was asked a question about uh
chemical weapons and he said if he uses
him will respond in kind now i don't
think he has the greatest understanding
of what he's saying on any given moment
especially when it's completely off
prompter but that everything they say we
did an incredible uh compilation on my
show a couple weeks ago of the mixed
messaging related to sanctions sanctions
will stop them sanctions do nothing
sanctions do a little sanctions do a lot
everybody from the president to sake to
kamala to the whole crew just saying
every version of everything
yeah
well you were highlighting the
inconsistencies the american people see
the inconsistencies and that's why at
this present moment joe biden's approval
numbers uh are are about those of a
really bad case of hemorrhoids and so it
makes sense that the american people are
they see through it we all see through
it um and it ultimately beyond the
political ramifications for the rest of
this year for instance in the run-up to
the midterm elections it also has
profound implications in terms of our
relationships with people abroad
because for instance when we start
sharing bits and pieces of intelligence
is that really true and we're asking
these countries to do things on our
behalf because of this intelligence
right so that's the cost from our
national security perspective
when they're putting out bogus
information or they're putting out stuff
that's even inconsistent with their own
values so if joe biden says that we're
going to respond in kind with chemical
weaponry are they going to pause and say
well
we don't want to hitch our nation's
wagon to this country america right now
because it's being led by a crazy person
who obviously is mentally incapacitated
to some degree and clearly is not able
to make good decisions or can't even put
out the right words to do so so
there's there's pretty serious national
security ramifications to his mumblings
and and we all see it it's reflected in
the approval numbers but i guarantee you
when capitals around the world right now
they see it too
how do we reverse
some of this stuff because okay we could
all say all right the errors always seem
to be in the democrats favor or the
leaks are always to the new york times
in the favor of the democrats et cetera
et cetera but this isn't just okay elect
more republicans and you're going to
save the intelligence services right i
mean what is the solution
well you know i mentioned jack kennedy
earlier he has a pretty famous quote
that i i love and i embrace and it's uh
you know when we seek out solutions let
us not seek the democratic answer the
republican answer but the right answer
and i think that most reasonable people
in this country understand that that's
really how you should govern and that's
how you should lead your own families
not necessarily in terms of your
politics but you look for the right way
to do things based on you know reason
and critical thinking
so the issue then is at this moment in
time
do we have two parties or two movements
or another party that we're not
considering beyond the democrats
republicans who are committed to
critical thinking to to reason
or is one of them just so wildly off the
mark that we just have to say look for
right now
those people are too crazy and that for
me
uh that decision was very obvious about
a year ago i left the democrat party
became a republican not because of any
you know profound affection or affinity
for republicanism in general although
i've always been a conservative but the
point is
we actually have people on the left
right now the democrat party which i've
been a part of for a long time was my
family who are saying critical
thinking's bad
right reason is bad
why because those are things that white
people do and white is bad
that's not hyperbole by the way they're
saying this you know this you've spoken
about this eloquently
so if that's part of the
the answer that people are when they
have to go to the the ballot box and
they're saying okay do i want
do i want to elect the people who don't
think that reason or critical
thinking is a good thing in fact it's a
bad thing because it's white like no it
doesn't even matter what the rest of
their solutions are those people are
crazy
and i'm not going to to to vote for them
now you very again eloquently talk about
that the left is is you know mentally
bonkers they're mentally ill and that's
true the party's full of these folks and
because they are so full of these sort
of panicked hysterical ways of thinking
that they're not responsible enough to
govern there are some democrats still
who are reasonable but they choose to be
quiet right some of the blue dogs for
instance they have chosen to just be
quiet to go along to get along um and
that's that's just not enough right i
mean there aren't enough of them and
they certainly are speaking up to say
yep
all right they're crazy elements but i'm
going to give them a shot because those
people are not in leadership and they
never will be so that's exactly why i
said at the beginning that we've had
similar political evolutions because you
were a democrat most of your life and
you've probably heard me say it but my
new line that i've been saying for about
a year and a half now is you don't have
to be a republican but you cannot be a
democrat that that seems like the honest
assessment it does not mean that these
guys are right and they screw up an
awful lot of stuff
yeah but as aoc said you don't have to
be factually right you have to be
morally correct that is that is some
dangerous
dangerous stuff
yeah well it's reflective of her
political movement which is not
liberalism it's it's marxism and she's
very clear although she hides it on
occasion or dresses it up in tick-tock
dance videos to make people think that
it's cute and fun but you are absolutely
right you have called this out
consistently and folks watching know
that that is absolutely
the truth
because we have eyes and ears and we
listen to people on the left right now
um you know the the video that went
around some time back of uh you know i
think it was dennis prager who who went
on the bill mayor show a number of years
ago and was talking about this idea of
sort of the trans uh movement and that
right now you know a bunch of people are
saying that men can menstruate and what
was so interesting uh is of course the
bill mayor and others were laughing at
him at the absurdity that anybody would
propose such a thing
but it was also that the audience the
audience was laughing at uh the
suggestion that men could menstruate
they all thought it was just this absurd
thing these crazy right-wing people are
saying but it turns out he was right
both then and now and other people are
making this argument look you're not
only are you telling us that we can't
think or we can't think for ourselves or
think can't think critically or with
reason but now you're actually telling
us to abandon basic biology basic facts
and so the question is why why are you
having us do this because this is crazy
and so politically speaking you're going
to start losing a lot of people who
otherwise identify as you know democrats
or you know moderate democrats even some
progressives that i've talked to i'm
sure you have as well they're like okay
i don't know where this is going uh
where it came from but this is really
weird um they want to be embracing
all kinds of different people and they
want to create a lovely opportunity for
folks to to excel in life but this stuff
of of you know the magic closet where
teachers right now are telling you know
trans kids that uh they can go into the
secret closet with the teacher and
swap out their clothes but don't tell
mom and dad i mean come on that's
ridiculous that kind of stuff that's
creepy it is grooming behavior and it's
wildly inappropriate yeah and people are
more upset with the label grooming than
actually what's going on in the freaking
secret closet and to your point about
dennis prager that was probably a year
and a half ago and uh you know just in
the last couple of weeks we confirmed a
supreme court justice who isn't a
biologist so she has no freaking clue
what the difference between a male and a
female is but but okay so let's let's if
if someone's listening to this and
they're like all right i won't vote for
democrats at least for now i'll vote for
republicans so now we get all the
republicans in we get the red wave that
that i pray will happen because we need
it at least for now
what will they do
that will fix the intelligence agencies
i mean what really is that are we just
cleaning house firing you know you hear
some people just fire everybody or close
i mean i hear people talking about just
close them all just get rid of everybody
yeah well look i think all options have
to be on the table and i think that you
have to understand that within the
department of defense the fbi the cia
and the nsa there is a history of doing
a pretty profound
investigation as it were panels on the
the house intelligence select committees
there was a church committee back in the
1970s when there are all kinds of
horrible things the intelligence
community the cia was doing they had
these conversations where they said look
you guys are out of control and here's
what we need to do to fix it so in other
words let's acknowledge there's a
problem and then let's talk about how we
fix the problem and i think that that's
where you need to start and i think
republicans would be very very wise in
both the house and the senate to have
those series of investigative
conversations those panels those
committee conversations and probably
many months long where you just start
you know airing some dirty laundry
inside the intel community some of the
bad things that they would probably
otherwise uh folks want you know they
don't want us to know about put it out
there and let's have uh you know some
solutions based on how bad the rod is if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell